pédagogie et soutient l'objectif était
double pour le secrétaire d'état en
déplacement à rambouillet pédagogie
économique d'abord avec la rencontre de
plusieurs entrepreneurs sur le campus
smartcity quelques jours seulement après
la présentation du budget 2010 8 les
acteurs économiques locaux ont profité
de ce déplacement pour interpeller l'un
des proches du président de la
république
on essaye tous les jours de développer
sa société dette au plus près ses
salariés a et c est le retour d'avoir un
ministre et quand très important ça
permet effectivement d'avoir plus de
visibilité d'avoir les deux et puis et
puis le soutien c'est déjà assez
désastreux en termes d'image et pour
nous c'est déjà très positifs et puis
bon je posais un certain nombre de
questions que j'espère qu'on aura
réponse à l'avenir ces chefs
d'entreprise pourront directement
interroger aurore bergé député de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines
la jeune élue a inauguré sa permanence
parlementaire sur le campus rambolitains
lors de la campagne présidentielle on
aura berger fut l'une des premières
politiques de droite a quitté le navire
et l'air pour rejoindre celui de la
république en marche
à l'époque fait d'avoir un peu de
courage et le courage dans la période
c'est un peu d'indispensable parce que
vous prenez pas la mer par gros temps
avec des gens qui au premier coup de
vent vous laisse tomber ou près de la
bouée ce tir du bateau en faire des
permanences tournant dans une dizaine de
villes de la circonscription
on va aller à la rencontre pas de nos
concitoyens parce que c'est il faut
changer aussi l'état d'esprit c'est pas
à eux de prendre rendez vous pour venir
à nous c'est à nous de venir à leur
rencontre elle la nouvelle permanence
sera notamment ouvert tous les mardis
sans rendez vous entre 10h et 17h